what's up everyone
Peter Combofiend roses here to discuss
Makoto in Ultra Street Fighter 4 dorinda
Khan Queen has long been grappling pose
in the Street Fighter 4 series and
although explosive
she's viewed as not all that threatening
when you're outside of her throw range
and also seen as a little bit linear
like to explore some of the more
pertinent changes to see if that's all
been addressed a pluralist crouching
heavy kick is a great tool to catch
those who are trying to jump away from a
potential command grab the big issue
with this attack however was that it did
less stun than the other heavy attacks
in the game leaving makoto players to
look for other options in an effort to
make this attack more effective the stun
has been increased by 80 acuto's light
and middle versions of the Tsurugi
attack are great for blowing up opponent
selected thrower used low attacks
constantly if it hits Makoto Cooke
connector ultra land of a combo or a
block keep her relentless pressure going
but that much worry of the opponent
countering in an effort to balance out
the risk associated with this attack the
quotas disadvantage when the attack is
blocked has been slightly increased when
done from the lowest point outside of DX
Hayate makoto had no real way to combo
off of her range attacks thereby
limiting or offense to help address this
her exp fiafia now extending opponents
as this is rather strong and can lead to
all kinds of new offense the damage and
stun associated with the attack has been
reduced to prevent it from being a
little too strong additionally this
attack has no invincibility so be
careful when throwing it out Makoto's
citizen glutes anxious he was
responsible for many combat so it was
very easy to connect off of a variety of
attacks due to the fact that this ultra
is almost guaranteed to land once per
round the damage has been reduced so
that makoto players will depend on it
less the portal's Alboreto tsunami ultra
was created with the idea giving makoto
away to fight projectile characters the
way it has been more commonly used
however was to avoid pressure and for
her to get out of jail free this has
since been adjusted with the removal of
the attack of its ability from the start
of the ultra however she still retains
two projectile invincibility
although McLaren has received a few
nerves she is still that much better
this time around she can now keep up the
momentum that much more due to her exp
yoga and cross the puffs whereas the
crouching hard kick will not run those
who try to jump away faster making her
that much scarier